new studies are in new science has
emerged on the coronavirus
here's the latest the virus very likely
started in the wuhan institute of
virology in the lab in china
china may have unleashed the virus
intentionally may not have been an
accident
people who have the virus very likely
don't need the vaccine because they are
very likely immune for life
and the masks very likely did absolutely
nothing in other words your uneducated
conservative uncle
who doesn't have very many degrees but
he's got a lot of common sense
was right about everything very likely
and the genius experts in big tech
in the media in the scientific
establishment with lots of fancy degrees
and very serious lab coats were very
likely wrong about everything
but hey at least we just let them shut
down the world
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show coming to you
live from a hotel room in south dakota
so bear with us if there are some
technical issues
my favorite comment from yesterday is
from archetype
goto who says he's responding i guess to
joe biden's atf
nominee alcohol tobacco and firearms
says what is a particularly lethal
gun phrase used by this nominee are
there guns designed to tickle people
no but you've hit on the point when the
left criticizes guns for being lethal
they're criticizing guns for doing what
guns are supposed to do
but they don't think that guns should
exist at all and they don't certainly
don't think we should have them
they say if we're going to have guns
they better not be lethal well then
what's the point of having
the gun doesn't make a whole lot of
sense somebody who uses that kind of
term as a criticism
probably should not keep his job and if
you need to replace somebody if you need
to hire the best people
go check out zip recruiter if you're a
business owner what's your most
important investment
is it the printer is it the fax machine
do people still have fax machines no
it's the people of course it's hiring
and when you're hiring i know i mean
we've done it a lot at the daily wire
sometimes finding the right person is
like finding a needle in a haystack
unless you use ziprecruiter zip
recruiter makes it really easy head on
over to ziprecruiter.com
knowles when you post unzip recruiter
your
position gets sent out to a hundred of
the web's leading job words but it's not
just throwing spaghetti at the wall
they will use their incredible matching
technology to go out and actively find
you
candidates zip recruiters so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day think about how long it takes to
hire don't forget time is money i mean
this is your business especially these
days we got thin margins right
no wonder over 2.3 million businesses
have come to zip recruiter for their
hiring
needs so while other companies overwhelm
you with way
too many options and i hate that i mean
even if i get like
texts at the same time i think i can't
handle this right use a recruiter it's
so simple they'll give you exactly what
you are looking for the needle in the
haystack
right now you can try zip router for
free at ziprecruiter.com
knowles what's that web address
ziprecruiter.com
canon wles zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire
i need to go through this evidence right
now before the fact checkers not only
take me off of
the internet but also bust down my door
and arrest my family because
you know the i mean we just made four
really big claims
that contradict basically everything
that these geniuses have told us for the
past year
the most important aspects of this virus
and yet turns out we were right the
whole time and the experts were wrong
first one this claim that the virus did
not start in a lab you remember this
now a year ago more than a year ago now
on this show and on verdict with ted
cruz
our other show we pointed out that it
seemed like a little
too much of a coincidence that the
coronavirus
that was associated with bats
that then became very transmissible to
humans
just so happened to be discovered in
this wet market that was um
400 yards away from the wuhan institute
of virology
where they study bat coronavirus isn't
that a little that's a little weird
isn't it
so we said it seems pretty clear to me
that the institute had something to do
with the virus if you made this claim on
facebook
it would be taken down you you could
have penalties on your account for this
this was a
debunked conspiracy theory all the
really smart fancy
fact-checking websites shut this down no
way you kook you crazy oh wait a second
now joe biden is ordering an
intelligence review of this
debunked possibility that it originated
in the lab
that's very strange that joe biden is
doing this because mike pompeo the
former secretary of state under trump
already had this investigation going the
trump the biden state department rather
shut down that investigation but then
the evidence became
so undeniable you had
researchers in the wuhan institute who
were who were becoming infected with
this
months before we were told the virus
broke out into the public these reports
leaked so now all of a sudden biden's
got to do an about-face
and now facebook's got to unban the
undebunked claim
that started in the lab number two and
this one is really controversial
about a year ago more than a year ago we
said you know china is an evil country
we've got an evil government and they
hide lots of things and we know that
they work on biological weapons
maybe this wasn't an accident and if you
made that claim oh my goodness gracious
you were silenced you were muzzled now
i'm not saying
that we know for certain that
the the virus was released intentionally
by the government
i'm not even saying it's likely i'm just
saying it's possible and it's not just
me saying it anymore
it is the white house through the new
press she's not the new press secretary
but she's the deputy press secretary who
held the briefing yesterday she was
asked
are you now that you're changing your
story on everything regarding this virus
are you still standing by the claim that
we know for certain that china did not
release this
intentionally here's her answer another
question on
uh kovid uh the language that you all
use specifically mentioned an accident
does that mean that uh you've ruled out
or the ic has ruled out that it was
uh deliberate or not an accident we
haven't ruled out anything yet
um again we're gonna go through this you
know this re-doubling down of another
of a 90-day review and we'll have more
to share
we haven't ruled out anything yet that's
not true you guys ruled this out
a year ago more than a year ago the left
they were out of office mercifully at
that time but through the media through
big tech through the scientific experts
they totally rolled that out a year ago
so now you're saying we're not well
we're not we don't want to rule anything
out that's a pretty big change in your
story
what would lead you to say that this
woman i don't have her name
uh she's filling in for jen saki whose
name i only fairly recently learned
but this woman is a black woman and the
way this was being reported in the press
yesterday i kid you not
they said so and so again her name
escapes me so and so
made history yesterday as the second
woman
to host a white house press briefing
i thought gosh you guys know less about
history than you do about science
it's not history when you're the second
person to do something you know i
remember that day
four years ago 2017 when i made history
as the third daily wire podcast host
wasn't that was so historic what a
historic day a slight digression
so here we go there's the first two
claims virus likely started in the lab
china may have unleashed it
intentionally
third claim oh now we're going to get in
trouble the people who had the virus
very likely do not need the vaccine
because people would have antibodies now
we're told we have no idea how long the
vaccine will be effective people might
need booster shots
and i've told you i've told you from day
one
that i'm in no rush to get this vaccine
why well i strongly suspect i had the
virus already
and i'm in a relatively statistically
young
healthy age group and so there's no real
risk from the virus for me there are for
other groups but not really for people
like me doesn't mean i can't get it
doesn't even mean i can't die from it
but just looking at the numbers things
are looking in my favor
new study out even a mild case of
covid19
can create antibodies that could give
you a lifetime of protection
from the virus quote months after
recovering from mild cases of copin 19
people still have immune cells in their
body pumping out antibodies
against the virus that causes covid19
according to researchers
at washington university school of
medicine in st louis which is a very
good school
this this is now being reported in study
fines such cells could persist
for a lifetime churning out antibodies
all the while
studies findings were published monday
in the journal nature so these are
serious
studies from serious universities being
published in a well-respected journal
but you've got to get the you got to get
the vaccine even if you're young and
healthy even if you've had the virus
well not according to the science not
according to the study just get it get
the jab get the
get the vaccine i don't think so
the vaccine there's nothing going on
with the vaccine no risk whatsoever
well actually we'll get into some
reports later coming out of connecticut
that we mentioned briefly on the show
yesterday
that suggest well maybe you know in rare
rare cases there could be a problem
and the argument for young people
getting it seems to be falling apart by
the day and then oh
man this is this is a really bad one oh
this one if i'm still on youtube
somehow this one's going to get me taken
down
i have been saying from the beginning
i'm actually saying
what dr fauci said from the beginning
namely that the masks
as a medical device do virtually
nothing to stop a pandemic
not saying they do nothing when surgeons
wear them in certain cases i'm saying
that when a bunch of people wearing
filthy cloth on their face
doesn't do anything to stop an epidemic
i've
been told by the big tech sensors i
cannot say that
well what if i'm reading a study what if
i'm reading the first ecological study
of state mask mandates i'm looking at
their data
and i'm noticing that they find that
widespread mask mirroring
wearing likely did not slow the spread
of covid19 this is a study conducted
by the university of louisville using
data from the centers for
disease control and prevention right so
this is the cdc
found that 80 of us states mandated
masks during the covet 19 pandemic
and while quote mandates induced greater
mass compliance right the mandates
did get people to wear the mask more
they did not
predict lower growth rates when
community spread was low
or high so yes the mass mandates are
quite good at getting people to wear the
masks unless you're a curmudgeonly
conservative like me and you and then
you wear it below your nose and you do
all sorts of
sometimes you don't wear it at all but
the mask mandates
didn't do very much to slow the spread
because the masks
don't do anything according to this
study to slow the spread
the study found quote mask mandates and
use and use are not associated with
lower soros cov2
kovid19 spread among u.s states our
findings
do not support the hypothesis that covid
transmission rates decrease with greater
public
mass use according to the study now what
do the man
the masks do something according to
these researchers
masks quote may promote social cohesion
as rallying symbols during a pandemic
but risk
compensation can also occur in other
words
the masks have one use
they are effective at doing one thing
acting as a political symbol but they
have
no medical use or scientific use
in the public during a pandemic in other
words
i hate to put too fine a point on this
you know how much i hate to say it it
kills me to say this sort of thing
i was right about everything i was right
so were you
so were you because i know that you guys
were
almost to a person on the correct side
of this issue
and the experts and the geniuses and the
squishy conservatives and the follow the
science people
were dead wrong about everything and by
the way now that everyone's changing
there too now that facebook's changing
it's tuned now that biden's changing
it's tuned you're here well you know at
the time
it made it made a lot of sense to follow
this no it didn't it never did they were
always wrong and we were always right
and you know what's going to happen
tomorrow when the scientific
establishment or
joe biden or the media or big tech i'm
repeating myself they're all the same
blob
when they tomorrow make some other
stupid claim
without any basis in reality and when we
contradict that claim tomorrow
when your conservative uncle who doesn't
have a bunch of fancy degrees contra you
know what's going to happen
they're still going to call us a bunch
of idiots and they're still going to go
listen to dr fauci
they're not going to learn a damn thing
but you should
we were right they were wrong we should
take that lesson
into the future the next time they sell
us a bunch of propaganda
have i made my point clear i think so i
think i have
gosh i feel i'm so invigorated just
makes me want to go work out
when you want to go work out i would
recommend checking out beachbody summer
is around the corner you know what that
means
that means that it's time to start
looking hot
sexy and fit i can't well i'm getting my
beachbody ready i'm doing it
with beachbody beachbody on demand
offers 1500 at-home workouts
plus nutrition plans they've got p90x
you remember p90x insanity the 21 day
fix well this is the company behind that
they've got some really great new
programs they've got muscle burns fat
they've got 80 day obsession they've got
celebrity super trainers like
tony horton joel freeman autumn
calabrese and michael knowles no that's
not that's not that's false advertising
i will not be training you you would not
want to see that happen
you can view the workouts on your
computer on your smart tv on your tablet
on your smartphone and your roku and
your apple tv
you can view them basically anywhere and
listeners to this show can try it for
free
do it just do it right now get in shape
feel good
shed those pounds 20 20 mercifully is
behind us
it's a new year which means it's time to
get into shape to get a special free
trial
no obligation membership text knowles
kwles 230
30 30. you go text that right now you'll
get access to the entire platform
all the workouts nutrition information
and support absolutely free 303030
that's right texas nobles canada wlas
to 30 30 30. the science
is changing the data are changing and it
turns out that the data the science and
the data now are starting to support
what anybody with two brain cells to rub
together and a modicum of common sense
knew
a year ago on the lockdowns on the masks
on the wuhan institute of virology and
the chinese communists
at least covering this up and even
according to the biden administration
even possibly
unleashing this virus intentionally and
yet
do you think do you think biden's going
to change course do you think
in terms of the day-to-day nitty-gritty
of the kovid lockdowns and the kovid
agenda do you think they're going to
change course no no actually
there's a study out that suggests that
people who've had the virus just don't
don't need the vaccine they've got
immunity they've got the antibodies
no they're not going to change course
joe biden just went on the youtube
channel of
mannymua can't say he's one of the
channels i subscribed to
he's some eccentric leftist youtuber he
went on there
with dr fauci and they made the point
still in their view that it is not just
important that you get the shot no
matter how
old you are no matter your risk group
it's not just preferable
it is your obligation to get the vaccine
there's a lot of rumors that are going
around that young and healthy people
don't need to get the vaccine you should
save it for people who
are a little bit older what do you guys
think about that both of your guys's
thoughts
they are not exempt from getting serious
illness so you want to protect
the youngsters be their adolescents be
their young children
you want to protect them there's no
doubt about it but then there's also
the responsibility that you have of not
being part
of spreading the infection throughout
the community
so you almost want to take what i call a
societal
responsibility protecting children also
protects society
i think it's an obligation an obligation
to help your fellow man
an obligation to make sure that even if
it's only a small percentage possibility
that you could be a carrier
of and spread the disease that you have
an obligation
you have an obligation they say there's
a point about this that is going to be
missed if you're only listening to what
they're saying
if you only listened to the interview
with manny mua namely
biden and fauci are framed in the shot
on video
as priests they are you can see it
go go watch the video later dr fauci
is sitting in front of a table that
looks like an altar in front of lamps
that look like crucifixes they do
and there are no mistakes in hollywood
okay there are no
very very few when people set up a shot
they are doing it
to convey a message to you and when you
look at fauci in the close-up with the
blurry background behind him
the the two lamps that i suspect were
selected for a reason
look it like crucifix is on an altar
because dr fauci is the high priest of
progressivism joe
biden too they're not making a
scientific point here they're pretty
open about that they say look you know
the science and the
risk groups and the demographic groups
and this they're making a political and
a social and
it's your ethical obligation it's your
social obligation
joe biden it's it's social it's moral
it's religious these guys
are our self-appointed
religious leaders in the religion of
secular progressivism and again you know
how much i hate to
tell you i told you so but gave a speech
about this months ago
that is what this is really coming down
to so is it your obligation do you have
to do it
do you let's say you're a healthy young
person
22 years old young
virile man do you need to go get the
vaccine well
there might be some risk i know we're
not allowed to say that there's risk
i know we're going to get taken off
youtube for this but i'm just i'm just
reading the headlines yesterday i said
you know i i'm hearing some reports that
there are
rare cases granted some
some issues with this vaccine i've heard
anecdotes from friends of mine
who got the vaccine and had some heart
issues had to go see the doctor
the doctors don't want to say that it's
because of the vaccine but they have
cautioned
these people i'm just speaking anecdote
anecdotally to maybe not get the second
dose
they're not willing to say it's the
vaccine but maybe watch out maybe don't
get that second dose
well some people have actually come out
and said maybe this is because of the
vaccine in connecticut
relatively small state 18 cases of heart
inflammation
in after covet 19 vaccination
here's the headline connecticut has seen
18 cases of heart inflammation after
qv19 vaccination
but doctors say teens and young adults
should still get the shot why
why should they because of the ethical
and moral and religious responsibility
well
first of all i don't look to dr fauci a
liar a guy who's repeatedly lied to the
public i don't look to him
for my moral and religious advice
what's going on you've seen multiple
people a lot of men but some women too
who are contracting inflammation of the
heart
myocarditis well michael how many
zillions of people have been vaccinated
you know come on 18 cases that's nothing
yeah sure i mean 18 cases are what we're
hearing about right now michael we don't
know that it's linked to the vaccine
that's true
just it's just the cdc's looking into it
so you know there's some evidence i
think that it might have something to do
with the vaccine
but furthermore let's say it's 18 people
in the whole
it's not it's more than that but let's
say it's 18 people in the whole country
if there is any risk whatsoever that i'm
going to
contract this rare complication
inflammation of the heart in otherwise
healthy young people
then why would i do it particularly if
i've already had the virus particularly
if i have the antibodies
which the other studies show give you
may very likely give you
immunity for life why would i do it
because fauci says so well what's
fauci's argument fauci's argument is
he said so that's his whole argument he
says it's socially
ethical it's we no how about we use our
prudence
we're not allowed to use our prudence
we're told prudence it's not a virtue
it's actually it's a vice it's
prejudice it's an irrational prejudice
just do what the experts even if the
experts contradict themselves every
other day
remember your your kooky uncle with a
good hunch
was right about everything and dr fauci
who's got all the degrees and all the
experts in the science was wrong about
everything
let that inform your decision-making
moving forward
you know thankfully some people
are taking political power back when dr
fauci takes all that political power
and when the left establishment wants to
give it to him it's part of the
progressive
project take the political power away
from the people give it to
the bureaucrats and the technocrats
woodrow wilson spelled it out more than
a hundred years ago
while that is happening right now some
republicans are taking the power back i
love this story out of idaho
the lieutenant governor of idaho just
signed an executive order banning mass
mandates not too far from me here in
south dakota
i think i don't i actually don't really
know i'm not not an expert on geography
but i it's good it's probably somewhat
close is it i don't know
anyway we'll i'll look at a map later on
how does the lieutenant governor
sign an executive order she's not the
governor well because
the governor was out of town for
for a little bit this lieutenant
governor was temporarily raised up to to
governor to deal with issues in the
state
when this happens 99 times out of 100 or
more
the lieutenant governor doesn't really
do anything just there in case anyone
needs
anyone needs him or her but this
lieutenant governor said oh i'm governor
awesome i'm going to start signing some
some executive orders so she signs this
order says quote
today as acting governor of the state of
idaho
i signed an executive order to protect
the rights and liberties and businesses
by prohibiting the state and its
political subdivisions including public
schools from imposing mass mandates in
our state
love the janus magician am i i'm
probably mispronouncing that
so then the governor comes back and they
say did you guys plan this and the
governor says no
i didn't know she was going to do this
but it puts him in an impossible
situation
really backs him into a corner what's he
going to do is he going to
rescind the executive order then he
looks like a squish then he looks like a
lib
no by the way this woman janice has said
that she's gonna run
for governor next go around whether he
runs or not
so he knows that he's got a political
threat from her i love it
but michael that's not orderly that's
not that's not respectable that's come
on we've gotta we've gotta be we've
gotta lose with dignity nope that's not
what this woman's doing
i love it i absolutely love it great
great stuff
we need to take power this sort this way
which he did totally legal
totally smart totally effective
highly doubt he's going to rescind that
mask mandate
now he's trying to get on the right side
he said we never had or that
anti-mass mandate he said we never had
mass mandates in idaho yeah good okay
well now you're not gonna
right unless you rescind the order we're
getting a lot of good news on the
political
political front as a matter of fact
the leader of black lives matter i'm
sorry that's not
the leader of blm which used to stand
for black lives matter now it stands for
by large mansions
you'll remember patrice cullers is
co-founder
of blm she's been in some hot water in
recent years
for a video that leaked in which she
said we are trained marxists that's what
we are trained in
so she's in that didn't get her into too
much trouble because her supporters are
totally fine with that
she got into trouble because she spent a
bunch of money buying up nice mansions
in los angeles and elsewhere she
defended it defended it blm defended it
defended it
certain blm subgroups got a little angry
because they said hold on give us a
little taste give us a little piece of
the action
that woman is stepping down before we
get to the mailbag
i've got to revel i've got to dance
in patrice colors being booted from blm
so when we covered this story whenever
it broke a month or two ago
oh they left they all downplayed it oh
it's not a big deal this is totally
justified patrice cullen she said i
haven't taken money directly from blm
which is i think it's basically true but
it's a little too clever by half she
might not have taken money out of the
debit card you know from
from the blm account but she
has a bunch of little shell companies
and she uses them as an extortion artist
to local governments to companies to get
money from them
through the cause of blm and she's
become a very wealthy woman doing it
so now she's announced just yesterday
that she is stepping down from the
organization
which comes as she and the organization
have faced widespread criticism
over not just the violent riots she's
happy about those
she's facing criticism for the
corruption for the extortion here
very glad we need to hold these people's
feet to the fire it's not cancel culture
i guess she's getting canceled whatever
if that's what cancer culture is sign me
up i'm all for it we need
to wield political power effectively we
need to wield executive orders
effectively i know there's this old
old idea it's not that old i mean this
is something that cropped up
i guess in the last 20 years of
conservatism
and it's really atrophied us it's it's
pushed by the squishes
you know the guys i'm talking about the
guys who
suggest that uh you know drag queen
story hour is a blessing of liberty
you know sometimes these guys are called
the french davidians it's like the guys
in waco you know
the french davidians there are there are
these guys
who don't want to wield political power
okay
older conservatives understood this i
was just speaking at yaf last night
about how william f buckley jr the
urbane
very respectable founder of the postwar
conservative movement
cheered on mccarthyism for a long long
time and even when he started to
criticize mccarthy
he still broadly defended the
mccarthyist project
it's good we we do need to do that we
need to do it in idaho
we need to do it on the mask mandate we
need to do it by booting radicals out of
the public square whether that's the
leaders of the blm
terror organization or whether that is
and i don't think i'm being hyperbolic
when i say that
michael not all the protests were
violent i'm not saying all the protests
were violent
but the organization has is explicitly
calling for the overthrow of society
right there
the overthrow of the cisgender western
family structure for goodness sakes
they are i think tacitly endorsing this
political violence and in some cases
it's explicit when maxine waters calls
for riots or when
when kamala harris bails the blm rioters
out of jail
the violent people out of jail
that is something we need to end got to
get it when nicole hannah jones
is not offered a job at a university
good good stuff love that speaking of
blm
there's a story on blm i want to take
from a slightly different angle
than we usually do this is a radio host
who
is a radio host in new york
she had gone on the air one day probably
many days and said
f the police seth the police typical
sort of thing you would hear from
blm or from the radical left and then
hours later she kills a police officer
in her car
take a listen i will see you guys next
monday at 6
30 p.m
back here on facebook reality radio on
the instagram and on the facebook
and until then the police
until then that's like her sign off
right and then hours later
this 32 year old woman jessica beauvais
uh hit hit a police officer a highway
officer in her volkswagen
he was redirecting traffic and she
killed him why did she come did she
target him because he was a cop no i
don't think there's evidence of that
but she was hammered she was drunk and
high in the studio she drank a lot she
admitted to this
to drinking a bunch to smoking a bunch
of pot and then
totally impaired she kills this guy she
killed
anastasio sacco's 43 father of a
six-year-old daughter and a
three-year-old son
he was redirecting traffic after a
separate fatal car accident
and she hit and killed him did you know
what her reaction was this direct quote
why did my first accident have to be a
cop not that i wanted it to be someone
else
but f i've been driving since i was 16
and haven't hit as much as a pothole
fairly callous and selfish response
but put all that aside for a sec she was
probably still drunk and high at the
time
i i don't see any evidence that this
woman was aiming at a cop i mean she's
saying gosh why did i why did i do this
it's going to ruin her life
the reason i bring it up is not to say
this is a terrible woman i mean she did
terrible things
if you get super drunk and high and then
get behind the wheel you are endangering
people
but i mentioned it to bring up what she
said on the show f the police
that's probably the last thing that
people are going to remember probably
the first thing
and the last thing people are going to
remember about this woman and i wonder
if she's got
any conscience in her whatsoever how
that's going to go
through her head she's going to remember
that she killed this guy
father of young kids because of her
irresponsibility and the last thing that
she said was
f the police not good stuff guys not
good stuff
you do not want to have these sorts of
regrets from a purely selfish standpoint
even
you do not want to live with this kind
of stuff on your conscience whether it's
acting responsibly and then hurting
somebody or whether it's even just
saying a cruel vicious thing
and then god forbid you know somebody
dies someone goes away and that's the
last thing that you're going to remember
you don't
want to live like that okay i joke about
it sometimes when i get
fan mail from the radical left get a
fair bit of it
i got one yesterday on instagram from
some gal and it was this
sort of vile stream of insults and
really mean things
and i responded and i said uh i don't
respond too many messages but i did see
it it popped up and i said
imagine saying this to a perfect
stranger imagine what it takes to go and
perfect strange and you go and you write
these vile things
and she had a good response she said i
don't need to imagine it
i said that was a softball you know but
touche two [ __ ] was a funny answer
but the reason that i respond to kind of
i just laugh these things
off is because i don't i don't want the
last thing
[Music]
that i've said to somebody to be
something vile
not even just for them not even just
because it's you know that's the wrong
thing to do
that's going to be on my conscience that
will sully me that will degrade me so i
don't want to do it
we do these things sometimes you lose
your temper whatever you know it gets
the best of you
but one wants to avoid it not not just
for the moral order but because
it's uh it's in your own interest too
you need to fight back against these
sorts of radicals you can fight back
without degrading yourself here's a
great way that someone is doing it right
now
a daily caller reporter is suing lori
lightfoot the mayor of chicago
daily caller news foundation and
judicial watch are suing chicago mayor
lori lightfoot
for discrimination because she refused
an interview to her reporter
now to her reporter to a daily caller
reporter thomas
kotnacci katnachi yo note
sounds a little bit like my people you
know the italian people
but lori lightfoot said she's only going
to grant interviews to brown and black
reporters
and i know the italians are pretty
swarthy all right we've occupied a sort
of interesting racial space throughout
history
but he's not black enough for her so he
was denied the report
this is discrimination he should sue her
this is good i like this
i like that but it's a threat it's
outrageous
we shouldn't be no it's good good to
exercise our rights this way
lori lightfoot should be cancelled
that's a very good thing
uh we we cannot tolerate this kind of
stuff
this rank bigotry well let's just go
along together let's
let's just only talk about tax cuts and
regulatory reform
and a bunch of squishes blow up my
mentions on twitter
to this effect misinterpreting
many comments i've made obtusely you
know in a way that might be sort of
disingenuous
as if to say that i i don't think we
should cut taxes this have to say i
don't think we should reform regulations
yeah we should do that those are all
that's all well and good i like a good
tax cut
much as the next guy but that's not the
only thing we should be doing and i
think a lot of
so-called conservatives but they're in
the squish camp they focus only on those
issues
because they want to be liked you know
they want they'll yo i'm just a quirky
conservative i just want to cut
regulations that's totally cool but on
any controversial issue on any issue
that
really threatens the liberal regime they
go silent
or they go impotent or in some cases
they support the the left
outright they vote for democrats in
crucial elections that sort of thing
that's not that's not gonna that's not
gonna help us fight back
okay that's not they're gonna they're
the ones who are gonna criticize your
crazy uncle and say oh follow the
science come on i'm not
i'm a conservative but i'm not one of
those conservatives well guess what one
of those conservatives you crazy uncle
who called all these things
he was right the whole time when you are
hanging out when you're chilling
when you're trying to relax the weekends
come long weekends coming up that's
great
you can watch more shows it's a great
time to watch more shows you can check
out
ben shapiro's new series debunked every
saturday
an audio episode of debunked will be
dropping you can
get the full 10 episodes of the first
season over at dailywire.com if you're a
member
if you're not a member we'll become one
you get 20 off today with code debunked
only while the discount lasts on
tomorrow's podcast
episode he's going to take on biden's
covid lies this will
you're going to get a lot of that you
obviously did get a lot of that today
then we'll be going into a bit also
tomorrow if you sign up now by the way
as a daily wire member with code vip so
that's another code you'll also get 20
off your new membership you'll also be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip for two
to the daily wire studios to see candace
live candace not just the show candace
but also
candace owens this deal will end on
memorial day so go check it out
dailywire.com
subscribe use code vip for 20 off
we will be right back with the mailbag
first question up in the mailbag from
matthew
mr knowles since controlling words is
controlling minds
do i get do we get a ding for that no
okay good i don't i don't know because
we didn't say the first part the book is
called speechless though
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now for pre-order you
can get it everywhere thank you to those
who pre-ordered
can we drop the gun in gun violence and
instead call it either just
violence or violence using a firearm
much like dropping biological from
biological man to refer to a man thank
you
uh perhaps i mean i do think there is
some utility you know there is a
difference between
shooting somebody and stabbing somebody
and punching someone in the head using a
club
here's one difference more people die
every year from clubs and bats and that
sort of thing than from
any sort of rifle including the ar-15 so
but but i think your point is well taken
why are we only concerned with gun
violence why are we not concerned with
bat violence knife violence in countries
that ban guns what happens you see a
spike in knife violence
so yeah i think that that's a good point
uh the reason we need to drop biological
from biological male is because it
suggests
that there's some other kind of male you
know there's a there are
non-biological males no there's not it's
just dudes okay it's dudes and chicks
that's what there is
but there are different types of
violence and i think we should focus on
it and even on the gun issue
we should we should not take the left's
bait they always want to say look we got
to talk about not just violence but gun
violence not just gun violence but the
scariest gun the ar-15 the ar-15 is
involved in
statistically just about no killings per
year
very very few pistols are involved in a
lot of killings
but the ar-15s are the big scary weapon
that the mean
white male republicans use and pistols
are what gangsters in chicago use so it
that
undermines the left's narrative on guns
and race and justice so they don't want
to talk about it but i think we actually
could talk about it i think that
distinction is worth having
question up from adriano adriana what a
good name hello my name is adriano i
know it's
written right there i'm looking for some
advice here from a fellow italian
catholic
about 10 years ago my then girlfriend
now wife got raped by a guy and had an
abortion to deal with the trauma oh my
gosh i'm so sorry to hear that
we were tight on money going through a
rough time
and were honestly just miserable after
what happened yeah of course you would
be
we have since gone through therapy gone
through confession
gotten married and had some kids we
become very emotional over
the fact that this year would be the
baby's 10th year alive
and we threw that away for nothing wow
i've been finding myself having
nightmares and crying which is not
normal
on top of this my kids found out about
the incident from another family member
do you have advice
because honestly anything would be good
right now here's my advice
saint paul was a murderer i had a guy
who was pretty uh
pretty mobbed up you know he was a bit
of a gangster in new york
now he's a total born-again christian
goes to mass every single day
he uh he said that to me once we were
talking about his story and he said you
know
saint paul was a murderer whoa
heavy stuff man saint paul was a
murderer
and he uh helped to seed the church one
of the
key figures in doing that uh
i'm glad i've never gone through what
you've gone through
i hoped that i wouldn't have uh you know
done it
but certainly the temptation would have
been there and it
other periods of my life i certainly
would have done it if i
during my atheist years oh i think i
probably would have
i would have come to regret it just like
you're regretting it but yeah probably
i think a lot of people do i think a lot
of people experience this regret and
you're seeing it right now because you
can you imagine how crazy it is you got
basically the worst thing ever
happens to your wife and to you also
and you do this thing and then 10 years
later
you're regretting that your wife didn't
have her rapist's child
why because you recognize you can see it
it's undeniable
that that baby is a baby but if you
asked anybody
what you did is that understandable
everybody would say it's understandable
of course
but now you've come to regret that too
we all have regrets pal everybody's got
a past
uh some things are worse than others no
no doubt about it
but you've you've confessed
you've received absolution i take it
you've got to be willing to accept that
too
you do have i mean it is it's not just a
feeling right and
in our faith it's not just like well i
think it's kind of a subjective feeling
it's a fact all right this is an
incarnational faith
with real sacraments that really do
confer forgiveness and really do confer
graces
and so you have received that
and you know there are temporal effects
of sin and you're
dealing with some of these but
not all the saints started well but they
all ended well it's a line from saint
john vianney
and some of them started off really bad
some of them did very bad things and
things i came to regret
but uh where are you now and where are
you going
i i will pray for you and your wife and
the
daughter and and that you uh that you'll
accept absolution and forgiveness and
you know
go on and have a good life from brian i
came out to my family about my sexuality
recently
i revealed to them that i'm a
gender-rigid half-bisexual
half-bisexual
gentle man what a great line my pronouns
are
i'm not such a towering rabid malignant
narcissist
that i expect the rules of the english
language to change to accommodate me and
my unique identity
they don't seem receptive to my new
identity do you think they're being
unreasonable thanks yes they are
they're being very intolerant very
close-minded and i say this i guess i'll
come out right now on the show too
i say this as a gender-rigid
half-bisexual myself
don't worry it gets better it gets
better okay you are seen
you are heard and your pronouns that's a
beautiful pronoun i love that not being
a malignant narcissist wow that's a
great problem
my best to you and your family i hope
they i hope they can come around from
hannah
hey michael just heard about the people
calling out to people on the streets
asking if they identify themselves as
jewish or not
you've seen this in los angeles and new
york people pro-palestinian lunatics
will run up and say are you jewish i'll
beat the hell out of them
as a fellow catholic i'm wondering if we
would be denying christ if someone like
that called out for christians to
identify
themselves and we just ignored them my
gut says to be silent and walk on
but where is the line between apostasy
denial of christ and just keeping your
nose to the ground well yeah i would not
recommend denying christ i think it's a
bad idea
saint peter did it three times and he
came to regret that and weep bitterly
and but then you know he turned it
around and made amends
if some guy is screaming at you on the
street you do not owe that person a
response
especially if you're walking with your
family or something like that if you're
walking alone if you're
if you're a guy i mean then maybe you'd
be a little more confrontational
however if somebody comes up to you and
really directly asks this question
you've got to give an answer
you know you're it's just not you if you
really find yourself in a situation
where you would be
denying christ tacitly or explicitly
i would not deny there was that scene
years ago of the cops the coptic
christians
who run on the beach and the
islamic terrorists were there and they
had knives at their necks and they say
deny christ
and they said we we love yeshua we
believe in yeshua you know they would
not deny christ and they slipped their
throats
and now those guys are in heaven so we
are we are called to that you know the
seeds of the church are the blood of the
martyrs and it's never easy for
christians sometimes it's a little
tougher than other times
uh so while well we don't owe people
a uh an answer as things become more
direct
you need to you need to defend your
faith or you won't you know
if you you deny the lord then he will
deny you
on i think he says that somewhere in a
book from hannah
hey michael i'm a college student in the
united kingdom
i think that's the equivalent to high
school junior year that's true
i know it's very difficult you brits
with all your
words that mean different things in the
american i was studying in the library
this morning when a class came in and
the teacher started telling them very
matter-of-factly
that george floyd's death was a racially
motivated murder and that america is a
racist country
i have one friend who shares the same
conservative values as me when she goes
to a different college so sometimes i
feel quite alone
quite is actually another word that in
uh
in america can mean very but in britain
can mean a little bit that's
okay anyway enough pedantic language
talk uh you know where you can get some
non-pedantic very gripping language talk
in my upcoming book speechless control
intro like where is controlling mine's
available now by the way for pre-order
it is there's that bell uh everyone else
seems to have very far left views do you
think i should stand up for my beliefs
more
or just keep my head down and get
through college thanks for all you do
p.s just oh
she'd give me a plug too just
pre-ordered speechless
so there is i guess that's a separate
one
i guess it's a similar answer to the
previous question
this on politics you don't
need to and it may not be even prudent
to go you know flaunting your politics
constantly all the time being very
flamboyant about it wearing the hat the
maga hat at the water cooler or
something
but likewise i wouldn't hide who you are
tacitly or or explicitly i wouldn't lie
and you do need to start practicing
integrity now integrity is one of these
things that you got to work on you know
it's
like virtue and vice their habits the
more you do them the more you'll do them
the easier they become
um so i i wouldn't hide and you'll get
lower grades and you'll you'll perhaps
be ostracized from your classroom but i
would be prudent we're called to be wise
as serpents and innocent
as doves so i'm not i'm not saying you
should be wise as a
dove and innocent as a serpent but but
you should when it comes down to it you
should
have integrity and stand up for what you
believe next question from john
hold the phone george will thinks that
representatives are scared of their
voters
am i missing something isn't that better
than the voters being scared of the
government
let me know what you think it's a good
point george will said on one of the
leftist shows
george whale a former republican former
conservative now i think he's a
libertarian party member or an
independent
george will said the gop is scared of
its voters
and uh they're they've lost all their
credibility and all their integrity well
yeah it's
good to be a little scared of your
voters you should still exercise your
judgment by the way
in representative government we don't
elect people so that they just do
whatever we tell them to do all the time
we are electing their judgment i mean
this is an insight that edmund burke
made
but we we should make sure that our
elected officials know who sent them
there and if they consistently
just diss us and ignore what we want and
then we should boot them out it's a very
good thing
good point you make a far better point
than george will did on that show
from suzanne i'm a new mother to an
eight month old girl with a second on
the way wow congratulations that's great
i waited until i was 36 to have my first
child and that is a regret in itself
but my real trouble is that i got into a
whirlwind romance with a co-worker and
decided that trying to have a baby was
what i wanted because i was getting
older and feeling lonely now i think
this happens to a lot of women
i got pregnant we married five months
later we decided to try for another
quickly so our children can have one
another
he's a good man he's a hard worker he
loves me in the family but i don't love
him
i realize now we don't have very much in
common and his family is relatively
awful
relatively that's a good that's a pun i
was good did you do that intentionally
i think love has to be oh sorry i am
determined to never be a divorcee
and to provide for our children with a
stable two-parent home
i think love has to be the foundation
and not something you strive for after
rash decision making
any advice on how i should proceed and
how to make my marriage work thank you
so much i don't want to downplay
true love you know i got to marry the
one got to marry a sweet little alisa
who just
is the sort of transcendent love of my
life and this has been
for a long time and even when we were
split up
for some years in there uh you know she
was still there
she was still kind of floating floating
in the ether and so then we got together
and that's a happy ending to the story
and not everybody gets that it sounds
like you didn't get that
romantic love and even more than
romantic love you know this kind of
deeper feeling of kinship the idea that
this is your soul mate the other other
side of your
person not everybody gets that
probably most marriages in history have
not been based on that
and there have been many great marriages
within those things
marriage is a fact as when we were
answering the question from uh
adriano earlier about how can he forgive
himself he did this terrible thing he's
received absolution
but you know and it's when he made the
decision it was a very complex decision
anyway in the sense that
i i think any of us could understand
making that decision even if we know
it's objectively wrong
any of us would feel a pull to do it
um and now god's forgiven him but he
can't forgive himself and now what do
you do
our faith is one that is sacramental
it's real we
to use a technical term where we we
partake of a
realist epistemology it's not just heady
stuff floating in the sky and it's not
just my feelings and my feelings it's
reality here you are married i think
it's admirable look you had some kids
that's great that's a wonderful thing to
get out of it
you say you never want to be a divorcee
good you shouldn't be a divorcee you say
he's a good guy but you just don't
spark's not there well that's fine maybe
the spark doesn't need to be there
all of our loves even our romantic love
is ultimately
just a faint shadow of our true love
which is oriented toward god that is
where our highest love is and we
can sublimate all of these sorts of
things so yeah you might
by the way over time you will you can
and i suspect will
love this guy that you just decided to
get knocked up and you know have a kid
i think you can and will love him more
if you work on that
that will happen you know when you see
really happily married couples who've
been married for 50 60
years they will say almost all of them
they will say you know i love my wife
today more than i loved her
even on the day we were married and
that's true i feel that way with my wife
you know she probably doesn't feel that
way about me she thinks ah this guy this
mess this bum he doesn't do the dishes
but i certainly feel that way
and you can feel that way i think no
matter how your marriage began
but the marriage is a fact okay and
you've got a good
a good thing going even if you know he
doesn't he doesn't uh you know pull the
romantic poetry out of you all the time
okay
and you can work on that because this is
a real world and you're in a real
sacrament you've got a real family and
you should be grateful about that and i
suspect you are
that's our show i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show see you on
monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 hey everybody this is andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin